من بعيد جاء يمني النفسه بالظفر بكوفيه
فلسطينيه اصبح هذا الوشاح في نظر كثير من
الناس رمزا للنضال والمقاومه واحيانا
شعارا
ثوريا ظننت انني ساجد هنا وللاسف خاب املي
لقد اصبحت الكوفيه رمزا
مهما في هذا المحل يجد الزبون منسوجات
والبسه واواني تراثيه وبعض ما ز الى
الموروث الثقافي للفلسطينيين وهويتهم يقول
صاحب المحل ان الكوفيه الفلسطينيه نفدت في
زمن
وجيز مع بدايه الحرب تدفق الناس علينا
لاقتنائها حتى الاسبوع الماضي كنا من
القلائل الذين تتوفر الكوفيه لديهم والان
نفدت الكوفيه بالاسود والابيض التي تسمى
عرفات حتى الكوفيه الحمراء لم تعد متوفره
لدينا بعض الالوان الاخرى باعداد قليله
جدا من غطاء تقليدي للراس الى رمز سياسي
تجاوز استخدام الكوفيه الفلسطينيه التضامن
مع فلسطين لتصبح عنوانا للنضال في العالم
ومع الحرب الاسرائيليه على غزه وعوده
القضيه الفلسطينيه الى واجهه الاحداث عادت
الكوفيه لتزين اعناق جيل جديد من مناصري
القضيه الفلسطينيه في شوارع
الغرب خلال المسيرات المؤيده لفلسطين من
الشائع رؤيه بعض الباعه يعرضون الوانا من
التراث الفلسطيني لكن لا اثر لايقونه
الثوره الفلسطينيه هذه
الايام نفدت كل انواع الكوفيه ولدينا
اتصالات مع مخيم للاجئين الفلسطينيين في
الاردن وامل ان نحصل منهم على كوفيات
بسرعه لان كل الناس يطلبون كوفيه انها رمز
المقاومه
الفلسطينيه لا تخطئ عين الوشاح الرمز خلال
مظاهرات التعاطف مع الفلسطينيين وشجب
العدوان على غزه يلف البعض الكوفيه حول
رقبته ويضعها اخرون وشاحا للراس او على
الاكتاف الكوفيه تمثل الشعب الفلسطيني
ومقاومته فهي رمز قوي وعندما نصد كلنا
فلسطينيون فاننا نعبر عن ذلك من خلال
الكوفيه لطالما كانت الكوفيه الرمز الاشهر
للقضيه الفلسطينيه ومع استمرار الحرب على
قطاع غزه اكتسبت زخما جديدا واضحت وسيله
النشطاء
والمناضلين للتعبير عن التضامن مع فلسطين
نوردين بوزين الجزيره
باريس